hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the gray
or not the gray gray man I was at all a
happy mood when I started this and then
it loaded up that intro thing if you
guys have seen it before and it kind of
got me in the mood like oh yeah I'm
playing this now oh I don't even
remember which way I came in I think I
came in through here yeah the hole in
the wall that's right did I come in
through the holes yep oh shut up oh man
I don't like this like seriously gonna
like this
Oh seriously I was all happy and like oh
yeah gonna play some video games and
then I got here and I'm a tougher than
this I'm a tougher don't oh yeah let's
go through that okay moving forward okay
there does not seem to be anything in
here yeah yeah yeah here who wants to
get funked sad nobody that's what I
thought
all the monsters are scared
weird growl on the backgrounds good man
yeah Oh text yeah no big deal
oh not water
hahaha not water what was that I saw
something of it
ah oh oh I want a wall what's this all
about
shut up chains needs to just shut up a
bit trying to concentrate
shut up
I'm trying everything I know are you
huh don't you dare get up don't get up
I've had enough with things get it up
when I welcome all your eyes are so
freaky so do not shut up
can use it
okay I'm just gonna meander over this
way
take that ah I'm sure there wasn't
anything over doesn't seem to be okay
I'm out of here I'm gonna I'm out of
here I don't like that then no mannequin
don't like it no no no no no nope
there was no point to going down there
doing nothing
nothing nothing at all ah no no no no oh
no there's no point to coming in here
there's literally no point come in here
at all
beside finding those things no no nope
nope come and save
no no okay all right I don't think I'm
supposed to go back you got to be
something I missed something
wait what's up there ah I see something
figure out a way to climb up there some
sort of secret huh okay hop from girl
yeah yeah some ladder can't climb it boo
okay I need to find some way to get up
there I don't know how though oh wait
here we go
aha I need to find some way to get up
there crawl through there to there so
where'd he go
oh no they were over here hi hey how's
it going okay maybe there's a crawl
space like behind something that I
didn't see usually use you looking up
I'm looking up I'm uh ha here we go can
you pick up this well I can move it
cover Oh get over here okay come on
there yeah almost there
okay good I don't think this is right
what
there's a hole in ceiling so obviously
there's a way to get up there nope
okay maybe not hop it huh Huna ninyo
okay all right that's not it that goes
down am i fall on your ass movies
this what this these doors are locked
okay there's got to be a way to get in
through there or at least even through
here let me check there's another way
there's another way in from the other
side I may be to get up that way but I
don't see how maybe some crazy cookie
agility on my part but it's possible I
suppose to get there if I really really
wanted to try Hey
save you save huh up fail tacular Oh No
perfectly goodness oh whoops no
nevermind I can't even get by this got
darn it
gosh dang it oh no matter
I'll fail oh I'm walking the police line
okay no I can get this hang on guys
this is exploration at it [ __ ]
one more try and then I'm going to stop
the ridiculousness but I think I can
actually do this hope hope back yeah the
cluster of imposing masonry and dark
alleyways finally gave way to the
familiar lights okay never mind
yeah is easier can you lay a running
start
hmm yes got it oh yeah oh ha ha yeah I
found one of Anita's what though okay
I'll take some smash you do dad as
opposed to that so if I continue upwards
I may find that there's something else
of value to me
come on I'll stay on their half life
FedEx ah alright after catching my
breath I instinctively began walking
towards work I was looking for a back
alright so I think I might be done here
but let me just try one more thing
nope okay that did not work even in the
brighter lights of the street shadows
seem to be creeping around the anti by
vision my FAC all right I don't think
there's anything else up there I didn't
even see like a window or whatnot to
climb up so I'm assuming that's about it
for this that was just some secret that
I could have gotten because I'm a super
epic awesome gamer and
oh didn't hurt myself just gonna go back
a bit just a double check that that
wasn't something else that I could have
gone into there's that thing but I don't
know I think I go back down in the
basement cuz after those things popped
up there might have been something else
that appeared down there I just didn't
want to go down there
bunk big bunk bunk
I got a rally noise alright
wat ah ah it's gone oh that was a door
closing I was like oh god I heard a
click behind it
shivers on my spine
yep it's gone how about that what do you
know
okay what's on the wall here doesn't
like anything important Wow
what's my flashlight fading I should use
that so much I don't think there's
anything down here
like seriously there's something in the
water maybe this thing is hard to see
that's just spamming my use but now
there's fast-paced ouch
I'm really not seeing anything guys and
gals please but
yeah I don't know what the deal is cuz I
just run here with nothing f18 one of
that means this MP I can't get into here
no there's nothing no way into there I
don't know if that's important or if
that's I don't wait that's all that's
here what oh sorry I missed that
what was that what am i grabbing what
are you grabbing okay there's nothing in
here anyway it's like everything else is
like there's rooms or there really is
nothing I don't know what to do it's all
it's supposed to be a big red herring or
what
I don't know I'm adding I don't like
that basement I don't like it at all
okay those guys are still there so that
must mean there's something else that
needs to be done
Oh what is it I hate to be doc but it's
my best feature
they're climbing climb oh yes just on
the wall just on the floor
what's this on the box oh I'm an idiot
oh oh I don't like this okay I'm gonna
check the other way because I I
obviously hate myself
nothing these aren't cobwebs these are
quite literally plants growing up in the
vents and that's weird okay it's dark in
here all right
making progress yeah all things have got
me going off really easily right now aha
I found it I found it this where it okay
huh I thought I saw something
save yeah super careful now stop it
nothing's happening it's really
disturbing me I've always said that the
best wargames make nothing happen for a
long time just to build the atmosphere
no no no that was the worst you don't
drop me into a dark room like that
totally unprepared oh I got Oh is there
anything here oh thank you I don't want
to go back there I don't
I gotta go back because it gotta be
thorough check out me
ah ah his gangly so freaky oh I don't
even know I don't even know I don't even
know you know I don't even know I don't
even know I can't even describe it right
now
okay ah be a trees okay all right I am
thoroughly freaked out and I'm all the
last time so I'm just gonna cut it here
thank you all so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
part
bye bye